Speaker 1: And speaking of lies, you can't
really talk about lies these days without
talking about Arizona, right.
That ballot audit that actually over the weekend,
reports came out, said, hey, it's drawing
to a close.
So, you know, that'll be fun.
I wonder if that'll be, you know, coincide
maybe with Mike Dels, Grand Cyber Symposium
this week.
But either way, an even bigger story came
out this past weekend about the Arizona audit.
And this one is truly disgusting.
And it also is representative of what we've
seen happen to officials all over the country
since the 2010 election.
A Republican member of Maricopa County Board
of Supervisors, man by the name of Bill Gates.
No, not that Bill Gates, but I'm sure that
doesn't help with Republicans.
He spoke with CNN over the weekend and he
said this.
Unfortunately, the threats continue and they're
not simply organic.
They're being driven, unfortunately, by members
of the Arizona State Senate and other Republicans
across the country.
We receive phone calls into our offices at
the Board of Supervisors, our staff, you know,
saying that our families are going to be slaughtered
and threatening us to stop standing up for
the good elections workers of Maricopa County.
So any Republican that dares to question the
narrative of a stolen election in Arizona,
any of them who dare.
Defend the integrity of that election in Arizona.
Are getting death threats.
We have actually seen this happening in Arizona
since I guess really since the audit started.
And there was actually videos of the angry
mob of trumpeter's, you know, that came in
there and wanted to get through and they weren't
allowed to be in there because it was a ballot
on it.
But we've seen those videos.
Georgia election officials mentioned earlier
this year they were getting death threats.
Even Raffensperger and his wife, you know,
the Republican secretary of state and his
wife said they were getting death threats.
It's happened in Pennsylvania, the death threats
are coming from these crazed Trump cultists.
Who genuinely believe that this election was
stolen, so anybody who comes out and says
the opposite must be the enemy, there must
be somebody to be destroyed.
And that is what they're threatening here,
folks, that that's that's where we've landed,
that's where we've gotten.
And it's sickening and it's disgusting and
unfortunately, the lies that are causing people
to get this worked up are not ending.
If anything, they're getting worse.
And there has to come a day of reckoning.
All of the abuse that these individuals are
suffering, all of the death threats that they
are getting, something eventually has to happen
to the individuals getting people this worked
up to to Trump himself, to to Mike Lyndell,
to Sidney Powell and Lin Wood.
There has to be accountability for Rudy Giuliani,
for anyone else out there spreading these
lies.
Accountability has to happen because people's
lives are at stake now and they're at stake
because of the lies being pushed by these
deranged individuals who refuse to accept
the obvious, and that is the public rejected.
Donald Trump, thank you for sitting here with
me today.
It's been an honor filling in for David Pakman
these past two days.
I will be back for two more days next week.
In the meantime, you can find me on YouTube,
YouTube, dotcom, fair and balanced YouTube
dotcom slash the ring of fire, Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram at Fair and Balanced.
Stay tuned for the bonus show.
That's some great stuff coming up there
Unidentified: for the November.
Have a great day.